our second speaker
our second speaker is Ben Mosley he's
coming to us from CMU he's an associate
professor at the Tepper in the
operations research group I have known
his work on using uh predictions in
order to improve the performance of
online algorithms and recently also run
times and today he's going to talk about
machine learning for optimization
well thank you so much I just want to
thank the organizers for putting on this
uh really amazing workshop and give me
the opportunity to be here uh so I'm
going to be talking about machine
learning for optimization uh and I'm in
the uh operations research group The
Carnegie Mellon University I also do a
day week it's a really exciting startup
uh relational AI
so the work I'm going to be talking
about here kind of pulls from several
different papers so these papers are
listed here at the bottom of the slide
so appearing in soda Esa acda and
narrips
um and they these Works were done with
really an amazing group of collaborators
uh you know the brains behind the work
are really the students my student
Thomas lavastida who just joined the
University of Texas at Dallas and uh
student Chen yang XU who is visiting me
at CMU for a couple of years Eisen
University in China
um and this is also done with Mike
deniza John Hopkins uh sung Jin IM at
the University of California Merced
Silvio La tanzi at Google Sergey
vasovitsky at Google and also our Robbie
who is in the or group with me at CMU
so machine learning as we all know has
been really transforming society and so
I can't think of an area of Science and
Engineering that hasn't been touched on
in some way
from machine learning
um now while that is true you know one
thing that machine learning hasn't
fundamentally changed in my personal
opinion is it hasn't fundamentally
changed the way we think about designing
combinatorial optimization algorithms
but what we're asking in a recent line
of work is you know well couldn't
so one of the major questions we ask in
practice often is well what is the right
algorithm that I want to use for my
given application and now what do I want
I want an algorithm that works really
well for the exact kinds of inputs that
I see in practice
unfortunately this is usually hard to
get and the reason it's hard to get is
because it's hard to mathematically
characterize exactly what those input
instances are right so what do we do
well we usually revert to some more
stylized form of analysis we go to worst
case analysis or stochastic analysis but
in both of these cases we lose something
and if you go to the worst case you're
optimizing for pathological input
instances that don't necessarily uh
appear in practice you go to stochastic
analysis it's not so clear in many cases
that your data fits a nice distribution
and what we would like is something
really tailored to the inputs we
actually see
now while it's hard to mathematically
characterize these
right
you know usually in practice we have
lots of data available and how do I
think about this I think this as we've
seen the problem in the past it's all
the yesterday the day before that
Etc
and so given that well maybe what we
could do is mine this data for some
information and we take that mining
information we give it to the algorithm
as a parameter and then the algorithm
self tailors itself to the exact inputs
that we see so this is the idea of this
releasingly emerging line of work and
it's one that I'm just you know I'm
super excited about this area
okay so for those of you haven't seen
this before thanks so yasi talked about
it but let me do a another warm-up uh
example so this example comes from a
paper of prosta at all Sigma 2018. so
here we have an array a of n integers
sorted so we start with assorted array
good now over time we get requests for
queries and they just say hey is this
number in the array and so for example
here we get a request for seven right
the race sorted so we just do a binary
search right to solve this problem we
say hey yes it's in the array or no it's
not good
right so worst case running time it's
going to take long and time you know
pretty much you know for almost
everything we search for it's gonna be
about login time uh uh worst case and
also in practice
all right but now consider the following
idea
I train a predictor h of Q okay so a
number comes in and I'm going to predict
where this number is in the array so for
example 7 comes in I say hey I think
Seven's here
could be wrong and so I'm going to start
my search from there looking for seven
I want to make it clear that this is
something that's very natural that you
might actually do in practice so let me
give you the following analogy before I
describe this algorithm so imagine you
going to a library a new library for the
first time
you're looking for a book by Tolkien
you're going to this new library you're
not going to begin your search in the
middle of the library right no you've
been to libraries before right so you're
going to start your search near one end
of the library because t comes near the
end of the alphabet right and so uh so
you start your search there same exact
kind of idea here so we predict we're
not the seven is in the array and we're
going to begin our search there right so
maybe our machine learning's wrong so
it's not exactly here the array is
sorted so we look left we look right
right we know which direction and seven
is in we start going to powers of two in
that direction until we overshoot the
number in which case we do a binary
search inside
so let Ada here be the error in our
prediction so from where we predicted
the number to be to where actually is in
the array or where it would be if we
inserted it
let's do a little back of the envelope
analysis so if Ada is the error in our
prediction well then what's the running
time going to be what's going to be log
Ada right so you do these powers of two
right takes log a Time binary search
inside login time and you can be a
little careful in practice or you
actually have to you know train this
prediction but you can make it work
okay so we can compare the two right
worst case binary uh binary search is
going to take log n time
a prediction algorithm is going to take
log eight of time so what does this say
it says that with a perfect prediction
we get the best possible constant lookup
time the absolute best we can hope for
right in the worst case Ada is in most n
the length of the array okay then we
match the best worst case algorithm and
in between we have a slow degradation
and performance right depending on the
error of our prediction this is exactly
the kind of thing we like in this model
perfect predictions right we get go Way
Beyond the worst case uh if there's a
huge error in the prediction we're still
bounded by the worst case and in between
gracefully degrading and they in terms
of the error of our prediction
options
all right so was the punch line it
should be taken away here from this
example the punch line is we can use
machine learning combine it with classic
algorithm design to obtain better
results now the thing that's becoming
you know really exciting to me in this
area is that what's emerging is kind of
a generally applicable model for Beyond
worst case analysis right so where's the
Armor's case analysis super exciting
area lots of really beautiful results in
this area but the one downside of it is
that often our models have to be
tailored to you know the exact problem
so we developed Beyond game worst case
funnels on a problem by problem basis
but here what's emerging is a kind of
widely applicable model we can apply to
many kinds of problems that I think is
really cool
so how do I think of this area right so
it's the series been called learning
augmented algorithms or algorithms with
predictions and the way I think of it is
the following so hidden from office is
some distribution over typical input
instances I don't know what that
distribution is good now we've seen
instances in the past so say I'm
scheduling jobs right I've seen the jobs
from yesterday the day before that Etc
that's my training sample
like it's fed in to some prediction
algorithm okay predicts a parameter and
then my learning augmented algorithm
takes that parameter as input right and
now you see a new instance drawn from
the distribution and you tailor yourself
to that instance
so what do we think about in this area
well the major questions we think about
are in this box
so first of all what parameter should we
predict not always obvious like what is
a good parameter to predict for your
problem uh uh is often a main question
that we ask and then given that
prediction well how do we
algorithmically use it I want to be
clear I hear that everything inside this
box is really just an algorithmic
question
there's no learning here it says what
parameter should we be predicting right
and how do we use that parameter
now it's also I believe equally
important of course that our parameters
right we actually can construct them
from past data right so we should be
able to show some evidence that whatever
it is we're using right we could
actually learn it from seeing prior
input instances right you shouldn't be
using something that say incomputable
okay so what's going on in this area
well you know I want to summarize the
results yes yes uh
comment on the last one yes
yes porn to have worse cash guarantee
when you don't understand how the police
actually you know current machine
learning we have very little result that
they learned something that's turnable
therefore we need to have worst case
guarantees if there's something that is
learnable it might be less important to
have worked with granted
so you're saying that in some cases we
don't really care if we can prove bounds
if you can prove that you can learn it
then you have good performance maybe
empirically prove okay yeah so but I
think in both cases you're showing
either theoretically or empirically that
there's some evidence here that we could
construct as well I totally agree though
thanks a lot
what's up good so what's the status of
the area uh so I want to summarize the
recent work but I can't do it there's
just too much work going on uh there's a
web page I'll show it at the end of the
stock and there's over 100 papers on
there on the last three years it's so
this is a lot a lot going on here
through all these works
people have looked at many different
models and I think that's great we look
at different ways of thinking about this
kind of problem but what I would like to
do is put forward you know the way I
think about designing algorithms in this
area so uh what I think is a nice
analysis framework
so I'll call it the Earl framework so
it's three pillars existence robustness
and learnability
good so existence
you know you need to be able to show
that there is some parameter for going
beyond the worst case
okay so in that earlier example the
binary search what do we do well we said
this location in the array so that
worked well for us predicting that
location is the example
um for a lot of problems I want to be
clear here the parameter like thinking
about what to predict is like kind of
the main question
next is robustness right what do we want
we want algorithms that are say robust
to minor changes in the problem input
instance or kind of our nearby in some
way right you should be robust when
things don't change so much
so for example go back to that binary
search right if we predict the wrong
location of the array it's kind of okay
we can correct for this error
dynamically
what would be a bad example right
imagine I just predict yes it's in the
array no it's not not so great right
like I can't really check that without
doing the worst case algorithm
and finally learnability so we need to
show or some evidence that our uh uh
predictions are indeed learnable so for
example
um you know maybe we could adapt like
the pack learning like setting we'll
talk a little bit more about that a
little later
all right so what's the agenda our
agenda's the following so first I'm just
going to give it an example of an online
algorithm and and so we're going to
parameterize the competitive ratio using
the predictions this is in the same
similar Spirit of what uh uh uh yasi was
talking about and then I'm going to talk
about running time and so here the run
time is parameterized by the error in
the prediction
right so the problem I'll talk about is
online restricted assignment make span
minimization good so we're in the
restricted assignment setting for this
this talk so M machines good jobs arrive
in the online list model was I mean just
think of them all arriving at time zero
one by one you assign it to a machine
you can't move it later the job comes
you sign the machine stuck there good
then after you sign it you see the next
job in the list that's the model and now
what do you want to do well you want to
minimize the make span what's the make
span this is the maximum load assigned
to any machine
clear make sure make sure I said clearly
machines and jobs list model one at a
time you assign then you see the next
job you don't know the remaining part of
the list every job has some feasible
neighborhood okay so it's restricted
assignment this means that each job can
be scheduled on some subset of the
machines
so n of J is a set of feasible machines
for job J
okay so for example maybe this green guy
can only go to these two machines this
red guy maybe can go anywhere
need not be any correlation between the
jobs in this way
now we could allow our jobs to have uh
varying processing times uh for this uh
talk what we're going to do is just
assume the jobs are all unit sized it
captures the complexity of the problem
so it just makes it a little easier for
me to talk about uh and all the results
will prevailing sizes so this just
they're unit size jobs
and what is my goal my goal is to
minimize the make span good all right
the maximum load and we'll let T be the
target so this is the optimal solution
all right all knowing optimal solution
if you schedule the jobs knowing the
entire instance
foreign
you know and try to design algorithms
for it well what I might do is use the
competitive analysis model right so here
we say an algorithm C competitive of the
algorithm's performance relative to the
optimal solution is bounded by C for any
instance what does that mean it means
that no matter what instance I see the
algorithms May expand as the most c
times larger than optimal
right
all right so I use competitive analysis
the problem's well understood so what do
we know we know there's a log M lower
bound
and on the competitive ratio any online
algorithm moreover we know greedy is
logout
I think greedy just says Hey job comes
assigns the machine with the least load
that it can go to so from a worst case
point of view the problem solved
up the constant factors these are
matching
it's all makes makes it look like
there's nothing left to do here
well the question is you know is the
worst case the right model do we really
know nothing about the jobs that are
going to come in the future
when we're assigning the jobs now a
reasonable assumption here is that we
have access to say last week's job
sequences if I'm scheduling a data
center today I've scheduled the data
center yesterday the day before that Etc
and so given that well we have these
instances right you know what should we
predict and how can we use this to
schedule jobs in this setting
all right so I'm going to show you some
predictions to fail I'm going to show a
prediction that works well in this
setting build some intuition
so first let's think about things that
don't work right now when I sat down to
solve this problem this is the first
thing we came up with and it you know it
didn't work for us uh one thing you
might do is say
predict for this new instance well
exactly how many jobs are going to be
assigned
to each machine in the optimal solution
schedule
all knowing offline you predict hey how
did that schedule sign the jobs what's
the load of each machine seems
reasonable right machines with a lot of
load just at an intuitive level like
these machines are very contentious so
maybe I'll try to reserve their space
try that but you know consider the
following imagine I have some really
difficult instance here described in
blue and now I create a new instance
from this same job same machines
but then I release a bunch of kind of
dummy jobs that can go anywhere
now what does the optimal do it just
smears all these dummy jobs and all the
holes I don't know which jobs which
right so uh uh uh what happens now is
maybe all the machines in apple have the
exact same makes band
so I gave you that information it's
worthless every every machine has the
exact same load I said you know just an
intuitive level that I'm trying to show
it's like this isn't such a useful
prediction seems natural but not
something before
another thing we thought about was dual
variables so maybe we would predict the
Dual variables for the natural linear
program for this problem
um this is a pretty good idea
and so in fact this works for a related
problem of matching in the random order
model uh and so this goes back to some
work long before this prediction model
stuff by Devon Hayes and be at all so
say think of bipartite matching uh one
side of the graph is arriving online a
guy comes you want to match him good all
right so they looked at this in the
random order model
and what they do is they read in a small
fraction of the nodes in the random
order don't match them
use them to construct dual variables
then using those dual variables in
complementary slack that's the Dual
variables that you construct tell you
how to assign the remaining jobs like it
gives you an assignment rule
right so effective what they're doing
they're reading a small portion of input
in the random order model they're
learning dual variables on that that
sampled fraction and then they use that
to get an online algorithm to do the
matching
what
in fact uh they can show doing this to
the random order model they get a near
optimal Magic
oh I mean given the matching is very
related to what I probably might think
you do the same thing you know it might
work but you know we uh we think the
Dual variables in this case were too
fragile
um and basically uh uh what happens is
the following so you can write down the
Primal and dual if I gave you the
optimal dual variables it gives you an
online assignment rule that if they were
you know they're truly optimal you'll
get a good uh assignment online but
if there's air in them we have problems
so
um really small changes like just a one
one plus one over poly n Factor change
and these dual variables completely
changes the assignment some cases so
there's we couldn't work with them in
terms of robustness
Ben yes please does it change the
assignment or the assignment quality
drastically that's it yeah do it so we
couldn't prove it so I don't have a
lower value but it's a very interesting
question uh and then we worked for a
while in it and it's just like this but
they just it's changed so much
it's surprising because this is
definitely what their favorite they
learn the Dual expression around the
model right yes they should be like
noise yeah but
yeah yeah but matching is somehow the
objective is less sensitive that's the
issue
questions
sorry yeah you are talking about
fractional assignment here or integral
assignment because does the the
integrality Gap uh
of course there was fractional
thank you
so it came out of these ideas like this
is a warm-up kind of what came out here
that you know okay so these don't work
but through lots of different ideas that
was here and others we thought of is
like what we want to know is something
about how contentious a machine is it
seems like an important quantity for the
restricted assignment problem
so we're going to predict something like
this so our idea is the following
right
um we're going to predict a weight for
each machine single number and intuitive
level lower weight means the machine is
a more restrictive higher weight means
less restrictive okay what the Wheats
are in a second but uh there's the
framework framework is predict weights
weights are going to give me an online
assignment rule but it's going to do it
in the fractional world so we're going
to smear jobs fractionally using these
weights and then separately from this
fractional assignment we'll round it to
an integer solution
so what are the weights
well so for each machine I we're gonna
have a weight WI
good
and now for a set of Weights I'm going
to tell you how to fractionally assign
the jobs how does it work
well each job J is assigned to machine I
fractionally as follows
like the job comes it looks at the
machines in its neighborhood and it
smears itself proportionally so each
machine it'll be the weight of that
machine over the sum of the weights in
the neighborhood just a proportional
assignment according to weights
well the thing to notice here right if I
gave you the weights this gives me an
online algorithm right for the
fractional problem right if I had these
weights then I just assign them this way
now of course you might be looking like
well you know
with this assignment role why should
there exist weights like this that are
close to Optimal that's not so clear but
you know for the weights there is an
online assignment role right if we do it
this way
okay
so the first thing is just showing
existence right so the existence part of
the framework right we want to show that
uh we could predict these weights so if
we let T be the optimal make span good
and we show there exist machines lights
that give us a fractional load
a one plus Epsilon t you can give me an
instance I can compute weights so it's a
totally offline problem we give a
polynomial time algorithm to compute
weights or if I assign them in the ways
on the previous slide right I'm near
optimal
all right now there's another problem
right what do we want but we want
integer assignment so imagine I give you
perfect weights it gives me an online
algorithm to do the fractional
allocation right but I want to round it
to an integer solution right but luckily
we can do that so in our work we show a
result but this has since been improved
by a paper of Lee and Xian and icml
what they show is say you have like T
Prime is your fractional load so that's
what you're trying to shoot for jobs are
coming they tell you the fractional
assignment you just need to round them
online right so it's nothing to do with
learning now it's just a rounding
problem uh uh good and so they show that
you can uh do this without losing log
login
now you might be wondering like why are
you losing this log log m
well in fact we've shown our work that
um this uh you know actually because
it's a randomized algorithm
posting scenes with high probability uh
uh uh we show that for any randomized
algorithm there's a lower bound of log
like that so another exists fractional
assignments where you're going to have
to lose this one
um you might be wondering like what
about deterministic algorithms
interestingly for deterministic
algorithms we show that
there's a lower bound of log M on the
round name so even if I give you the
fractional assignment online
deterministically the lower bound
matches the worst cases if I gave you no
information
uh I also should be clear this is all
about the really difficult case when uh
you know the makes band is really small
and optimal like if they make spending
Optimal Solutions large like bigger than
log M you just do randomize around me
you're getting your Optimal Solutions
but this shows that these weights exist
right so this is the existence part
yeah totally so the log
so some constructed with weights or you
have a fraction suit
but for constructive with such weights
or any practice like
oh good so yeah we just look at this
totally separate problem where I just
give you the it could be that like
around those factors I guess so yes
that's true that's true
so I'm hiding in the back that my unit
time jobs here that I'm assuming the
options at least one generally speaking
without the sun processing time
that's true
[Music]
all right so what do we have we have the
existence right next part is robustness
okay one of the predictions are wrong
right so we have it online I predict the
weights now I'm going to use them to
assign the drops
all right so the robustness guarantee we
give us the following so for each of the
weights
let's look at the maximum relative error
so the weights I predict relative to the
weights I should have been given look at
the Max uh uh relative error
ETA good and we show uh that we can kind
of correct for this error and we give a
competitive ratio that's the minimum of
log eight and log M for the fractional
problem uh so if you just use the
weights you lose something polynomial in
Ada um so our algorithm realizes online
that there's some error and corrects for
it dynamically pushing it down to login
but uh now you can combine this with
that rounding and overall what do you
get well you get the minimum oh and I
should say here right there's the log m
uh so we get the minivlog logata if the
air is really big but we're still
bounded by the best sports case
you throw in the rounding uh and then we
get the minimum of uh log M so the
rounding Times log ETA
so in particular if the predictions are
really good we're going to do great
right and then in the worst case we're
still bounded by the login
please uh do you have to do work to show
that the log log M disappears from the
second branch in the Corollary
uh it's not so difficult
all right so then what do we need well
we also want to give some evidence that
these weights are indeed learnable that
you could find you could construct them
from prior instances all right so let me
talk about ways you could do this for
you know a general framework could apply
to any problem
right so imagine there's some unknown
distribution D like there's a
distribution over input instances good
right something you might want to do is
say hey I want to compute say the best
prediction for my algorithm what does
that mean I want to get the prediction
that an expectation or out my algorithm
has the best performance
good
all right and now another a question you
could ask is like well okay to show that
this is computable give up on the middle
time algorithm that using a small number
of samples
we can compute a prediction
for the expected performance the
algorithm with the prediction is nearly
as good
as uh having the best prediction of high
algorithm notice here they're not
compared to the optimal solution okay so
all I'm doing is saying I'm finding the
best prediction for my algorithm right
for this particular distribution
so you can look at that model
uh so this model is similar to pack
learning or this really exciting area
people have been working on data driven
algorithm design
um so that's one way you could look at
it another way you could look at it is
by going competitive analysis so before
we're comparing the algorithm to itself
best prediction for the algorithm
another thing you might do is show that
a small number of sample with a small
number of samples you can construct a
prediction
right with the expected performance the
algorithm is nearly as good as the
optimal solution
and of course this is going to be much
harder so here on comparing to Ops not
the algorithm itself
so what do we show but this is just to
give some evidence that these weights
are learnable right so we show that D is
a product distribution and the alpha
will make sense large so two very strong
assumptions removing these assumptions
very interesting to me
um but then we show that indeed you can
compute weights given a polynomial
number of samples polynomial time you
can compute weights that are
um
nearly optimal as compared to the
optimal solution for that distribution
risk minimization on the past set of
sequences
okay do you know what like sort of
settings here where you don't want to do
empirical risk minimization well yeah
for some settings you could just prove
they're good like compared to apple or
something use it it's totally reasonable
like you know it's too stochastic
analysis right and so you throw away
around and just you know just found it
totally impossible to take their
distribution
[Music]
so I'm just curious whether there's like
like in your experiences
where to prove
you need to sort of hedge your weight so
totally
um I'll have to think a little bit
offline yeah nothing's like that okay
yeah I'm sorry guys I guess on that
point there's like this and there's also
robustness fix that dude in dialysis on
stage so like how much do you need to be
robust chair versus
yeah yeah so there's a there's a
question about being robust here and the
learning part versus the online
algorithm measuring different things and
so they're almost they're just different
files yeah that's an interesting I mean
generally but you show different things
okay
coming from the new models
all right so that does it all so
existence must learnability referral
model right so we showed the weights
exist go beyond the worst case you give
me good weights we're robust to errors
in the predictions right and then we
give some evidence that they're
learnable
all right so that's what I want to say
about online algorithms just to mention
here like there's just a ton of working
on online algorithms uh uh uh
what if I say that they exist some good
weights I don't assume my distribution
to be a product distribution
would that be a possibility or you have
an account for example that some example
okay yeah so yeah so that's something I
thought about I just don't know the
answer so okay
cool so right so there's just tons of
work out there it's supernatural like
that people will be considering this
right so you're using predictions to
deal with uncertainty in the online
very natural case of using machine
learning
and so that's where most of the work has
been done when I go back to the original
question right so go back to the
beginning of the talk we were looking at
this binary search
that's we're improving run time right
but to think about can we speed up
algorithms using this predictions
so this brings us to the idea of warm
start so many problems are solved on
similar input instances over and over
again in practice so really anything
we're going to spend a lot of effort
trying to solve we usually solve more
than once
right
scheduling yesterday scheduling today
yeah when we analyzed the running time
of our algorithms it's always in the
worst case hey we just throw away that
information that we have from solving
them in the past right so we're like
Dory here like we get a new scheduling
instance we totally forget about the
jobs we scheduled yesterday why are we
doing that right what are we going to
use some of that information to help us
solve our problems
in the future
right so that brings us the idea of warm
start so maybe we can warm start the
algorithm of something from the past
now I did some literature search here
um I could find combinatorial algorithms
that use warm star but there were all
heuristics so they didn't have
theoretical guarantees
um so one way of kind of viewing this
work is putting the uh warm start on a
theoretical Foundation that said if you
know of works I would love to to read
them
so go ahead so what are the pitfalls
right so as before we want robustness
and learnability right so if I predict
something I predict uh uh for the
running time
you know it might not be feasible right
so I predict something it might I might
start in an infeasible state right so
somehow I need to get back to
feasibility is going to be a big issue
then even if what I predict is feasible
sometimes I need to very quickly
optimize so I need to do better than
what I could do without the prediction
and then as before right of course I
want to show these things are learnable
whatever my starting States
so what's wrong I'm going to look at I'm
going to look at weighted by part-time
matching good so we got a bipartite
graph we have costs on the edges cij
think of it as a complete graph for this
talk let's say we want to compute A Min
cost perfect matching on this complete
graph you might be wondering like why
don't I look at max weight matching uh
because in practice often to solve that
problem you would use the Hungarian
algorithm first thing it does is it
converts it into a Min cost
political impact
all right so what are we going to
predict well we could predict edges in
the optimal solution
some intuitive level this felt too
brittle to us and the reason you know it
might be okay but we don't have the
lower bound but you know if I change the
weight of one Edge a little bit like the
optimal solution might take an
augmenting path switching all the edges
in the solution right so it just seemed
brittle to predict edges so what we're
going to do is we're going to use linear
program duality
so what do we got we got the Primal dual
Trying to minimize the cost of the edges
we pick so xe's do I pick an edge zero
knot good for every vertex right we got
to pick and educate Jason to it for
perfect matching good
it's going to minimize the cost so Min
cost perfectly matching right so what's
the Dual for each vertex we have a price
so y i is the price on vertex I good and
what the constraints say it says Hey for
every Edge
at the sum of the prices on the
endpoints can be most the cost of the
edge
and what do we know we know by
complementary and slackness that edges
in the
optimal matching they're going to have a
tight dual constraint
all right so let's say we want to solve
this problem using Hungarian algorithm
how does it work at a high level and if
we give all the details but uh it starts
with the Dual values at zero so it's a
primal dual out it starts with dual
value is a zero and it's going to raise
them up over time at every point in time
it maintains a feasible solution
good all right now it goes through these
iterations and so in each iteration or
it's going to push up some some of these
uh uh uh the prices on the vertices then
what it does is it finds all the tight
dual constraints and these correspond to
edges
throws them into a set
then you go find a Max cardinality
matching on that set and if it's perfect
that's a proof that it's optimal that's
a perfect metric
if it's not what do you do well by
Hall's theorem
right there's some set like that
violates right there's some set that
violates Hall's theorem and this
immediately is going to tell you you
know which dual variable is a push up in
the next iteration
I level this is outwards
so notice here it starts the Dual values
at zero
what we're gonna do well just predict
the Dual balance very natural
start the algorithm from there
all right so we're going to warm start
Hungarian with these predicted dual
variables first thing we're going to run
into is a feasibility issue right we
want to be robust right and so if I use
if I predict these prices right they
might violate the Dual constraints
right somehow I need to deal with that
right so the the Hungarian algorithm
always maintains something that's
feasible and so in particular it might
be the sum of the prices on an edge is
more than the cost
so it's our idea our idea is we're going
to take the these prices and reduce them
as little as possible to make these
constraints feasible and do it fast
we set up the volume optimization
problem it's really simple it just says
hey
you know this is how much your Delta is
how much am I going to reduce the price
for design and you got to reduce it
enough to make the constraint feasible
from the original
so we don't solve this directly we give
a simple greedy algorithm and it gets it
to approximations to this in linear time
and this is good enough for us
good right so predict the duels we
basically project back to feasibility
using this greedy algorithm right so
they could be in feasible move it to
feasible it's uh you're reducing the
values basically as small as possible
nearly as small as possible good and
then from there Hungarian algorithm
doesn't care where you are it just
starts you can just start running it
so our theorem says the following it
says Hey the runtime is going to be the
L1 Norm difference the predicted rules
versus the optimal duels
times the time it takes to run the
cardinality Matrix
and you can show that you're bounded in
the worst case by the worst case run
time with Hungarian algorithms so
intuitively the error if this is really
close to Optimal like it's reducing the
weighted matching down the cardinality
matching
all right so I have uh not much time
left but let me just uh you know go over
uh uh some experiments so uh you might
be wondering does any of this stuff work
right ah well okay so first
let's look at some synthetic data
all right so what is the synthetic data
we just uh here we want to show like the
conclusion we want is if there's
something to learn right our algorithm
does well
so good
uh all right so we plant a matching a
very low cost edges and a bipartite
graph then we add noise to all the edges
some of the edges get kicked out of the
matching by doing this uh with the
planted matching but in general that
most of those edges remain in the event
cost matching and so there's something
to learn so good and what do we see the
the learn dual algorithm
it is uh performing fewer iterations of
this this Cardinal image
your iterations of the hunger
good so that says hey if there's
something to learn we learn it now what
should you also expect well if there's
nothing to learn the algorithm should
not perform better but we hope it
doesn't perform so much worse than
Hungarian okay so what do we do well we
really crank up the noise here we add
all the edges basically is you really
increase this noise what's going to
happen is it's going to kick out all the
edges that we planted there right and
then it's just a random graph and of
course with a random graph there's
nothing to learn and so we see we're
doing better and then we revert back to
the performance close to the performance
of The Hunger
so that matches our intuition this is
good
then we uh like okay what about real
data
um good so we ran in a bunch of
geometric data sets
um so here we're finding you know the
Min cost matching of these points uh
where the edge lengths are the euclidean
distance
um and we just sub sample these I can
get more into how the sampling goes
um but basically what do we see I uh we
see we're never running worse than
Hungarian sometimes it's pretty modest
our Improvement in other cases we're
getting a 10 times speed
okay so what's the conclusion
maybe there's something going on here
where we can get some speedups by
predicting
finally
um you know our Theory says we need a
polynomial number of samples
right to be able to construct for dual
variables
well what about practice right so how
many samples do we need we ran in all
the real data sets and uh basically what
we observe is that after a small number
of samples we see separation between uh
the the learn dual algorithm Hungarian
so we don't need so many samples in fact
we don't need like proportional number
of nodes in the graph or something to
start getting some improved
so that's what I wanted to say uh
so interesting questions uh in this
model like so you could look at your
favorite problem of course but some
things that I'm interested in is like
can we separate predictions right are
there predictions that aren't learnable
but way more powerful than learnable
predictions intuitively that makes sense
but I have no proof of this I have no
example so that I think that that uh um
it's an interesting question uh
generally you know you could look at
this model for online algorithm designs
to help you cope with uncertainty you
know you might use it for running time
offline you might design data structure
learn data structures
um but there could be other applications
for different models for instance I
think that's right for say figuring out
how to apply these this this technique
or something like it to say some
stochastic optimization problem
uh
but uh and so I'll leave you here with
this link uh so this link there's this
is where people have been dumping papers
uh anything that appears you can add it
here so this is a huge list of papers
and people have been tagging it with
what's going on in the paper
for that thanks so much for your time
everyone
[Applause]
let's take a couple of questions and
then
so in this uh like framework you're
using like a frequency approach yeah are
you thinking about like Point estimates
and okay
but like like does this uh are there
settings where taking this approach so
that is interesting and it's something
that I've been trying to think about so
uh
it's usually a very nice
and more videos
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and you'll have to
just have
like yes yes
to the fact that you are learning faster
than Therapeutics or because you are
less sensitive to error and curability
because I have two type of air learning
and robust sensitivity
so you have a normal one error that I
found like how error in prediction can
impact performance of algorithms and you
also have like an error on how fast you
can do yeah so my question is what which
one do you think is inflated in theory
versus huge
conversation yeah
do you think you're learning tools can
be applies itself in general in your
programs but it's a very interesting
question I don't know how to do it but
it's a super interesting question
so let's take more business plan